qué tal bienvenidos de nuevo en el vídeo
pasado estábamos encontrando el volumen
bajo una superficie y a lo que llegamos
fue a esta integral vamos a resolverla
para ver qué nos queda mira nada más
descubrí que puedo mover la pantalla
hacia abajo y entonces ya podemos tener
más espacio para trabajar pero bueno
como le hacemos para evaluar esta
integral pues veamos en la integral
interior estamos integrando con respecto
a x es decir estoy sumando todas las
pequeñas alturas moviendo el valor de x
como ya lo habíamos mencionado en este
dibujo de acá es dejar fijo e integrar
con x variable déjame cambiar colores
entonces cuál es la anti derivada de xy
cuadrada con respecto a x ésta es fácil
de hacer es simplemente x cuadrada entre
por una cuadrada entonces xx cuadrada de
cuadrada entre dos ahí está y tengo que
evaluar con límite superior 1 y con
límite inferior x igual a raíz de esto
de aquí puede asustarnos un poco pero
vamos a ver que no es tan difícil una
vez que lo evaluamos déjame poner la
integral de afuera de 0 a 1 y poner aquí
de ella ahora si x es 1 cuánto vale esta
expresión pues esta expresión queda
simplemente ya cuadrada entre 2 y
cuadrada entre 2 y ahora hay que restar
el valor de cuando x vale raíz de y
vamos a ver que nos queda si x es raíz
de y nos queda raíz deje al cuadrado que
simplemente es g y luego hay que
multiplicarlo por una cuadrada
entonces nos queda cúbica déjame
copiarlo aquí abajo de kubica y hay que
dividir entre 3 vale entonces ahora
tenemos que tomar la integral con
respecto a y es decir tenemos que sumar
estos rectángulos en la dirección de iu
nos queda de 0 a 1 y aquí nos queda de
ella y esto está padre lo ves porque
cuando tomamos la primera integral con
respecto a x estamos dejando fijo y así
que la respuesta queda como una función
de y más aún también tenemos límites en
función de y y aún así las cosas no se
complicaron mucho pero bueno volvamos a
lo que hacíamos cuál es la derivada de
esta expresión ya cuadrada entre 2 - ya
kubica entre 3
pues saber la anti derivada de ye
cuadrado entre 2 es que cubica dividida
entre 3 pero con el 12 hace tres por 26
menos llega a la cuarta entre 4 por 3
nos queda 12 no la regué por aquí en
algún lugar a ver que kubica en 36 - ye
cuarta entre entre a ver déjame poner
aquí ya cuadrada entre 12 ahí esperan un
poquito de dónde saqué este 3 de aquí
aquí es donde me equivoqué debería de
ser un 2 más bien a ver déjame checarlo
a ver nos queda x igual a raíz de
entonces raíz de g al cuadrado nos queda
ahí porque cuadra de kubica pero el 2 no
tuvo por qué hacerse 3 el 2 siempre
debió haber sido un 2 entonces más bien
habría que dividir entre 2
saleh sí verdad sí sí sí nos queda entre
dos cuando tomamos la integral nos queda
ya la cuarta entre cuatro que nos queda
4 x 2 que es 8
tengo que asegurarme de no hacer este
tipo de errores me choca cuando pasa eso
pero prefiero tachar un poquito a
repetir todo el vídeo pero va ahora si
quedo bien la anti derivada es llega a
la cuarta entre 4 y con el 2
nos queda 4 por 2 que es ya la cuarta
entre 8 ahora sólo nos queda evaluar
esto en 1 y 0 y restar entonces ahí va a
quedar un sexto menos un octavo menos
puros ceros así que pues los ceros no no
los ponemos porque no nos importan bueno
el pongo aquí 10 de este modo nos queda
esta resta de fracciones cuánto nos
queda el denominador común es 24 aquí
arriba nos queda 4 menos 34 menos 3 nos
queda 1 entonces es un 24 un 24 ago efe
estoy aquí es el volumen del sólido que
queríamos encontrar
ahora como lo hicimos en esta ocasión
fue que integramos primero con respecto
a xy luego con respecto a y no te da
algo de curiosidad ver qué pasa si lo
hacemos al revés a mí si vamos a hacerlo
voy a borrar algunas cosas por aquí a
ver voy a dejar este dibujo grande pero
todo lo demás lo voy a borrar ahí está
este es mi borrador profesional
electrónico aquí está voy a borrar aquí
abajo vamos a hacer mucho mucho espacio
para poder trabajar bien y ahí está a
ver
fíjate voy a dejar esta gran figura pero
lo que sí voy a volver a dibujar es el
eje x pues justo lo que quiero es que
sigamos practicando esto de encontrar
las regiones de integración entonces ahí
va ahí tenemos el eje
ahora este de acá es el eje x
i
x
ok entonces nuestros límites superiores
esta curva de aquí y ésta estaba dada
porque es igual a equis cuadrada o como
también ya lo habíamos dicho puede ser x
igual a raíz de y aquí nos queda x 1 y 1
y lo que nos importa es el volumen sobre
la región sombreada
vale vamos a dibujar nuestro nuestro de
a es decir nuestros pequeños rectángulos
entonces lo voy a hacer con color rosa a
ver eso es como un color rosa mexicano
va
entonces la altura es de y eso ahí es
una y su ancho es de x entonces el
volumen el volumen sobre este pequeño
cuadrado este de acá en 3d es el acá
entonces el volumen sobre esto es el
valor de la función en ese punto
entonces nos queda x porque cuadrada y
lo hay que multiplicarlo por el área de
esa pequeña de esa pequeña superficie
entonces ya sabemos que llevamos llamado
de a pero es lo mismo que deje de x este
signo de x no es necesario es si quieres
puedes no hacerle caso y ahora escribí
la aie primero porque lo que queremos
hacer es sumar primero con respecto a ya
que quiere decir sumar primero con
respecto a y pues mira lo que vamos a
hacer es sumar ahora verticalmente estos
cuadrados que estoy poniendo por acá
entonces lo que queremos hacer es sumar
todas las desde entonces mi pregunta es
la siguiente cuáles van a ser los
límites de integración
el límite superior otra vez choca con la
curva fíjate choca por acá entonces cuál
es a ver vamos a poner una equis fija
para preguntarnos esta pregunta bien
bien entonces ya que tenemos una equis
fija cual es la altura de este punto
entonces nuestra altura es igual a equis
cuadrada porque justo ese es el valor
que nos da la curva y el límite inferior
está más fácil verdad el límite inferior
baja choca con el eje de las equis
entonces eso lo que nos dice es que el
límite inferior es cero
entonces esta expresión como está
escrita por el momento es el volumen que
está sobre esta región marcada de aquí
cuando dejamos una equis fija es una
rebanada de jamón cuando esta rebanada
de jamón la hacemos paralela al plano al
plano receta entonces es una cosa de
este estilo va ahora lo que queremos
hacer es sumar todo todo todo con
respecto a x para sumar el área de todas
esas rebanadas es decir queremos sumar
los volúmenes sobre estos rectángulos
entonces vamos a poner nuestros límites
de x va desde x igual a 0
entonces voy a ponerle aquí desde x
igual a 0 y luego integramos todo eso a
este límite superior x igual a 1
vale entonces ya tenemos una expresión
más para encontrar el volumen del sólido
de acá
la forma en la que lo pensamos es que lo
último que se hace es lo de afuera tiene
que ver mucho con la composición de
funciones que afuera ponemos de equis
entonces primero tenemos que dejar fija
x y entonces trabajamos con lo de
adentro entonces va otra observación al
final todo nos va a quedar un número si
tus límites de integración tienen una
variable hasta el final es porque algo
está pasando mal entonces hasta afuera
siempre debe haber números en los
límites de integración sin embargo
adentro dejando una x fija aquí vemos
que el límite inferior tiene que ser
cero y el límite superior tiene que ser
x cuadrada pero bueno vamos a evaluar
ahora si para ver las cosas más
concretamente y entonces lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es integrar con
respecto a y entonces nos queda x de
kubica entre 3 porque x es constante
acuérdate evaluado hasta x cuadradas
desde cero y estamos integrando de 0 a 1
de x
si ponemos x cuadrado en vez de y nos
queda x cuadrada al cubo que se quizá la
sexta y multiplicada por otra equis más
a ver voy a escribirlo aquí entonces nos
queda x x x al cuadrado al cubo entre 3
eso de ahí es igual a x a la 7 verdad x
cuadrada al cubo es 6 por otra xx a la 7
y hay que dividir entre 3 menos esta
cosa de aquí evaluada cuando ya es cero
pero nos va a quedar cero entonces no lo
escribimos evaluamos de 0 a 1 la
integral y ahora hay que integrar
finalmente con respecto a x
ya casi terminamos entonces otra vez
aumentamos el exponente en 1x a la 88
por 3 nos queda 3 por 8 24 y esto lo
tenemos que evaluar desde 0 hasta 1
y creo que vamos a obtener lo mismo no
les da emoción no les de emoción si es
un 24 - 0 y una vez más cuando
integramos en el otro orden de
integración de todas formas obtenemos
que el volumen es 1 entre 24 espero que
te haya gustado nos vemos